what about the guy what about the
professor remember he was from x-files
yeah oh no that well you see i had lunch
the john neville john neville i had when
i was a ratta boy
and i was all patches on my sleeves you
know
and uh talking like madonna in london um
royal academy brad um we studied
some of those performances and john
neville had done
othello on the west end with richard
burton
when the entire audience was teenage
girls because burton was so beautiful
you know with his strategic acne scars
and that beautiful voice that sounded
like silver thunder
and and they would all do the matinees
the girls the teenage girls would all
ditch school
go to the matinees to see burton and
neville
and burton would swap roles one night
he'd play othello in blackface
politically incorrect and then the next
night he'd play iago
so i go out to lunch in downtown toronto
at this
elegant old restaurant with john neville
and of course i know all this
so i i start asking him these questions
and no one's asking these questions
in 50 years so it's little robert
england you know
sitting there you know but i you know
i've got my little goatee
and uh and my george clooney haircut and
i'm and i'm being
a subtle fanboy with john neville but he
loved it so i got all this
gossip you know about judy dench
give me something give me something that
nobody knows
judy dench apparently was wild and helen
mirren
he said helen mirren every time she got
a she got on stage she had to take her
clothes off you know she always wanted
to do a nude scene
helen mirren always wanted to be naked
apparently that's what he says when
neville told me he goes oh
oh helen hello she she did king leo
naked if she could
she loved i guess she loved apparently
she had a lot of nude scenes
at the old but when you're naked at the
old villa or the royal shakespeare
company that's really something you know
yeah wow that's pretty amazing i
remember
yeah john neville was great i remember
that one line i just always remember
goes
the weekend that we can eat
if you look at if you if you if you imbd
him it's amazing oh yeah he's done
everything
yeah to see the stuff he did i think he
was sort of the new john gilbert
you